oh endless hat hair i didn't think this through
hi it's michelle from lab muffin beauty science
chemistry phd skincare nerd and newly qualified
cosmetic chemist yes that's right i felt so
awkward about people accidentally calling me
a cosmetic chemist that i went off and got a
diploma that is how bad i am at confrontation
today i'm not quite talking about sunscreen
i'm talking about things you can use
instead of sunscreen i can feel my sunscreen
propaganda shill bucks slipping away right now
time to stop eating avocado on toast i guess
as much as we all love sunscreens sometimes it
is a bit of a pain in the what what in the butt
you have to apply it right you have to apply
enough sometimes they can give you rashes
and clogged pores they rub off
they can feel uncomfortable
so it seems like there has to be a better option
right today we're talking about hats and umbrellas
i think most of us have seen this swiss cheese
diagram which has to do with covid protection
there are lots of different types of protection
each one has some shortcomings but if you have
enough layers of imperfect protection then
they can add up to give you overall pretty
decent protection and i think this is how
we should think about sun protection as well
sunscreen is one layer it's imperfect it
should be used in conjunction with other things
in australia we have the slogan slip slop
slap seek slide slip on a shirt slop on some
sunscreen slap on a hat seek shade and slide on
some sunglasses but how well does each one work
why do we still get burnt in the shade can
we wear a hat instead of wearing sunscreen
let's start by talking about where uv
comes from it obviously comes from the sun
but there are two different types of
uv exposure which you might remember
from my video about whether or not
you need to wear sunscreen indoors
we have direct uv exposure this is where the
sun is falling on your skin when you're in the
sun you have direct exposure when you're
in the shade you have indirect exposure
then there's indirect or diffuse uv exposure this
is where the sun's uv bounces off something else
onto you usually that something else is air
molecules high up in the sky but sometimes it's
also the ground or other objects around you this
bouncing around also happens with visible light
which is why you can still see things when they're
in the shade shorter wavelengths of light get
diffused more so there's more diffuse uv around
the visible light and more diffused uvb than uva
if you're standing in the middle of an empty field
then out of all the uv coming in towards you about
60% of the uv you're getting is diffuse and 40%
is direct these percentages are very rough and
they change with lots of different factors
like how high the sun is in the sky where
you are in the world what time of year it is
what wavelength of light you're talking about
but the key thing is the uv shining directly on
you is actually less than half of your total uv
working out how much direct uv you're getting is
pretty straightforward if the sun is shining on
you then you're getting that direct 40% working
out diffuse uv is trickier we need to work out
how much stuff is bouncing uv on us if you're
outside the main thing bouncing uv on you is
probably the sky we can use something called
sky view to work out how much uv we're getting
so if you're standing outside in the middle of
a field you can imagine that you're surrounded
by a dome of blue sky that is 100% exposure
to diffuse uv and the amount of diffuse uv
you're getting is proportional to
the amount of sky that you can see
if there's stuff between you and the sky then you
have lower sky view and lower diffuse uv if half
of the sky is blocked out then you're getting
about half the diffuse uv so if you're standing
right next to a building and you're standing in
the sun then you are getting that direct 40% uv
plus half of that 60% diffuse uv that gives you a
total of 70% of the uv that you would get compared
to standing in the middle of a field if you're
not in the sun but half of the sky is blocked so
you're standing next to a barn but the sun's moved
and now you're in the shadow that means you're not
getting the direct uv anymore you're not getting
that 40% but you are still getting half of that
60% you're getting 30% of the uv you would be
getting if there was nothing else in the field
now in some situations the ground can also reflect
quite a lot of uv most surfaces absorb most of
the uv that comes in so this is like grass dirt
ashphalt apparently americans call this bitumen
but there are some surfaces that do reflect
more so apparently in some countries there's
this thing called snow and that can reflect
up to 90 percent if you're standing in this
so-called snow the snow can actually bounce up
more uv than the sun and the sky combined sand
can be 10 to 40 percent depending on the
type of sand concrete is around 10 percent
so depending on the uv index even if you're
standing in the shade all of this bouncy uv
can still add up so that's why you can still
get burnt in the shade if you're standing and
you're facing the sky or ground that can bounce
up uv you can still get a lot of uv and remember
uvb wavelengths get scattered more when you're
in the shade you usually feel quite cool because
visible light and infrared which is
90% of the energy coming from the sun
that's the stuff that heats you up and it's
getting blocked but that uvb can still bounce
around and get onto you if you face away from
the sun then the uv bouncing onto your face is
going to be cut down by a lot even though
you feel around the same temperature wise
so hats and umbrellas basically portable shade how
much protection are we getting let's start with
hats hats are usually made with thick material
that will block out almost all the direct uv
so an akubra hat which looks like this blocks
out everything but one two-thousandth of the uv
so this leaves 0.05% getting through but of course
if you have a hat made out of thinner
fabric then the uv is going to increase
you might remember my video about upf
clothing the same points apply here
so if you're looking for a hat that blocks out
more uv you're looking for a synthetic fabric
with really tight knit basically you want
really small holes and as few holes as possible
if you have a few layers then that helps basically
the less breathable it is the better it is
intense colors are also better because fabric
dyes can absorb uv the bigger the hat the
more sky it's going to block out and if the brim
turns down it's going to be a bit more protective
than if the brim turns up because you can see
more sky off the side so for example this hat
is probably going to give better protection than
this hat even though they are around the
same size but they do give you hat hair
this is a terrible hat for sun protection i don't
know why i bought it i do because i was pressured
to by space nerds if you're wearing a cap like
this you can imagine a little man standing on your
face he's gonna still get a lot of sky view it
will be blocked over here but you're still getting
all of this plus you're getting some direct uv
every once in a while as well shining on your face
but a little man standing here in the
middle of your head is going to get
a lot less sky view he can't see all of
the sky up here but even with a broader
brimmed hat there can still be a really
big difference so a little man standing
here near your forehead is going to get a lot
of sky view blocked out by this bit like that
hats don't work with fringes
so in general the forehead and the nose get
the least sun exposure the cheeks and the
chin get the most because they're further away
from the brim they're not getting their view
blocked out by this brim as much as if they
were up here and for parts of your face that
are angled upwards the hat is going to block
more a little dude lying on your nose is going
to get more stuff blocked out by a hat than
someone lying on your face and looking sideways
but of course there's also the ground a
hat isn't going to protect you against
uv bouncing off the ground which could be a
significant problem if you're somewhere like
in the snow one study estimated that with
this akubra a farm worker in queensland
would drop down their yearly exposure of
uv down to one-seventh for their forehead
one-third for their nose but by less than
a half for their cheek their overall face
protection factor was two to six but in some
parts of their face it could be up to 100
now with umbrellas we can think of these as
like hats but further away from your head
the further away it is the bigger it has
to be to block out the same amount of sky
if the umbrella doubles in
distance from your nose so
maybe to here then the radius has to double
to give the same amount of protection
one big difference between hats and
umbrellas is that umbrellas tend to
be made out of thinner materials so usually
more direct uv can get through and this can
be really variable in studies it's been found that
regular rain umbrellas can let through as much as
23% of the uv or as little as 0.1% unsurprisingly
given what we know about fabrics from upf clothing
black umbrellas work the best and
also umbrellas that have a upf rating
this umbrella from uniqlo claims to be
upf-40 which means it lets through 2.5% of uv
i'm not sure i believe the upf rating
for this umbrella but it's supposedly
bigger than 50 plus so it should
be letting in less than two percent
another difference with umbrellas is you're
usually off to the side with an umbrella so
one side of your face can get a lot more uv and
depending on where your umbrella is and how wide
it is you could actually be getting more uv
exposure with your umbrella than with a hat
but on the bright side you don't get hat hair
annoyingly for our purposes most studies have
been done on beach umbrellas which are stuck in
the ground and much bigger overall in studies with
beach umbrellas you can get a protection factor of
between 3 and 17 depending on the size of the
umbrella where you are under the umbrella the
thickness of the umbrella where the sun is and so
on another study estimated that if you're sitting
in the shade under an umbrella in the middle of
summer and you're not wearing any other protection
as illustrated by these helpful but slightly
creepy diagrams you can still get burned in
two hours so here are the takeaways hats and
umbrellas are great for giving uv protection
that you don't need to reapply and won't wear
off quickly they also project areas that you
might not easily be able to cover with sunscreen
or clothing like your scalp or like the edge of
your eyelids although there are sunglasses for
that that will be a different video they're
particularly good for protecting against direct
uv but it's that 60% diffuse uv that gets you
these umbrellas and hats only really protect the
circle of sky right above your head there's all
of the edge where stuff can bounce in to project
against diffuse uv you're going to need sideways
protection like a wall or trees to get between
you and the sky or you can go for something that's
closer to your skin like sunscreens and clothing
if you're in a high sun exposure situation
remember the swiss cheese layers don't just rely
on one type of protection use multiple types
high sun exposure includes going to the beach
and exercising in the sun in lower uv exposure
situations like if you're only going outside for a
few minutes or if it's in winter unless you're in
one of those places that gets this snow thing then
you're going to need less layers of swiss cheese
so i hope this video was useful you might also
like my videos about whether or not you need to
wear sunscreen indoors whether or not you need
to reapply sunscreen how to reapply sunscreen
my video on sun protective clothing and
maybe just my sunscreen videos in general
like subscribe nerdification bell
check out my blog check me out on
instagram and i will see you
next time for more nerdery